what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to do a Super Bowl catch-up
of three trailers that we did not cover yesterday
we're gonna watch the Super Mario Brothers ad the
Indiana Jones of the dial of Destiny ad and
the Creed 3 spot as well so of course join
with John how are you I am good sir how
are you doing great ladies and gentlemen
first order business go ahead you can leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated also
um one of the best ways to support the channels
check out some of our awesome merch like who
influences the influencers reject Nation beanies
real rejects oh it's so much attire I'm really
proud of this one here with the design myself yeah
there's video chapters if you guys want to hop
around but go to shopzeroedition.com get yourself
some apparel of the reject Nation represent yo
[Music] all right so the first we're
going to start off with let's check
out the Mario commercial it's only 30
seconds long let's see what's going on
all the things
Nostalgia yeah thank you for Super Mario Bros it
seems like the only thing you haven't drained is
my bank account for Super Service call or text
Super Mario Bros Plumbing today oh my God two
nine five five Mario or reach us on the world
wide web at smbplumbing.com we're making a phone
call right now sir let's see what's going on with
this phone call that's cool that's got to be like
the commercial that plays in the actual movie
but the Nostalgia with that element yeah yeah
no flashing back to like all the classic like
extraneous Mario media of the 90s oh here we go
hey if you need service please text us at the same
number you just call 92955 Mario
that's nine two nine five six two
[Music] oh I know mansion and
we'll be sure to text you back
let's go
foreign
that's some great marketing right there it's
yeah great Charlie Day Luigi right there it's
got to be a commercial that plays in the actual
movie before before he goes into the Mushroom
Kingdom is what I imagine before they get sucked
into there yeah yeah I'm at maybe we'll see the
prologue is Bowser attacking sure and then we
do like where's a lot of serious and [__] yeah
and then it goes into like guts to Black and then
for the Mario Brothers yeah yeah super marketing
budget that's right I love it I love it good all
right let's see the Indiana Jones one next [Music]
that we met my memory is a little fuzzy
once a Nazi always a Nazi oh
yeah hang up [Music]
rescuing you and Jesus danger and he has to go
rescue her yeah that's funny it's funny stuff
because it's a version of expectations I mean
Indiana Jones classic spectacle here liking it
some of the younger Harrison Ford not looking
as good as it first did uh this one shot or
very early on where Toby Jones is messed up in
the background that is it looks like deep fake
it's got that it's got that weird like it's got a
blow around it yeah yeah it sounds like it feels
like it just had a piece of plastic peeled
off of it and it's like brand new silicone
or something like that yeah it's still a fun
little teaser for what's to come yeah it's
got all the swashbuckling you could want it's
got you know the the stamp of the time period
it's taking place in you know it looks like an
Indiana Jones movie and it doesn't look too far
out there like a crystal skull I'm not sure yet
if we should react to it or if we should just go
watch in the theaters and enjoy it for ourselves
and then talk about it still not sure what to do
no right it depends on if it's uh if people say
it's great you know yeah if it's another Crystal
Skull then we should watch it on TV if it's a
great Indiana Jones send off we gotta check it
out on the big screen I think it'll be better
than Crystal Skull but who knows if this movie
sucks it'll go get your Crystal Skull Defenders
rising to the surface oh yeah that's all it
takes what have you done for me lately all right
let's watch this 45 second spot for Creed 3 next
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back now he wants to take you
anymore now he wants to break it hey
I'm just getting started little bro
I'm coming for everything can't
get over that body muscle Beach
Dodger Stadium let's draw everything
dude this one I'm in major conflict over whether
or not we go react to it ever here wait for it
to come out on VOD I know or go to the theaters
because uh the early reactions were saying I'm
a sucker for IMAX and they were saying the iMac
shots in the box now because I've always wanted
to see that I've always wanted to see that ever
since no one came on the screen with you know the
Dark Knight films like man be so cool to watch
a boxing match with IMAX cameras and when I hear
when I hear how cool it is I'm like ah damn that's
like the main thing I've been championing for and
I feel like I might have made my decision already
it's just now okay so it's fine I'll sit here and
react to it and you go too thank you I appreciate
it I'll take the bullet you know and I don't want
to spoil anything of quantumania for you guys
nothing at all um I'm sure but when Creed shows
up it's crazy it's crazy they've really broken
the Multiverse I know I'm saying that when uh
there's that fight tease in the main trailers
yes where Ant-Man and King are throwing fish the
Cuffs at each other and the way Jonathan Majors
moved there I got pulled out for a split second
it went I can't wait to see him in Creed yeah
yeah yeah yes holy crap is he ferocious well
that's the thing is he I mean you know he looks
scary as keg certainly but this looks utterly
scary yeah and it's such a rocky style premise so
it's all personal and they have like you know the
the shattered relationship from the past yeah
and then just all this anger that the Jonathan
Majors character Damien was built up over time
like I I feel like it is gonna give them a run
for their money in terms of just sheer epicness
and emotionality well I think I'm gonna have to
go watch this on IMAX well maybe I'll decide
later but the early reactions have been like
overwhelmingly positive and I know that's usually
the case but I don't smell [__] with those early
reactions sometimes you can read between the lines
I'm like people being pretty straightforward about
how like freaking epic and cool this movie really
is the Rocky movies had their and downs if Creed 3
wasn't terrific I feel like people wouldn't have
too hard time it's too hard at times saying so
you know alrighty guys well before we go what
did you think uh of the Super Bowl's trailer
spots we did not get a little mermaid cost too
much money or something like that to put out but
guys leave a like check out the other reactions we
covered for the Super Bowl and last but not least
James Smith I wanna fight you this is me throwing
down the gauntlet it's on man as Creed is the
freshest in my mind but it's okay because you
know we have a destiny to fulfill we will have
to dial in our choices in this life that bring
us closer together but also closer to tearing
each other apart but then think about it maybe we
meet in the ring maybe we throw fisty cuffs and
realize that we have a bond all along not unlike
that of two brothers and then maybe from there
we can let all of that anger go and just go start
unclogging people's toilets and things like that
and you know fixing pipes you know maybe uh eating
various uh you know fungi and things like that I
feel like we can put our differences aside James
Smith and we can walk out of this as you know
a super set of of real brothers so I hope you're
doing well this month this February and I hope
you know tomorrow's Valentine's Day I hope you're
doing something nice uh you know getting a little
romantic and uh we'll catch you next month
for St Patty's Day catch you buddy [Music]